sembler douce et bienveillante dans sa manière de bouger--
et à un autre moment sembler violente et conflictuelle.
C’est la même structure, juste le mouvement qui change.
Acteur: « Tu veux savoir quelque chose ? alors, tu veux savoir quelque chose ?
Il était déjà mort !
Simplement posé là, les yeux vitreux ! »
(Rires)
Se déplacer de façon gracieuse est juste une étape de l'ensemble de la structure
appelée interaction homme-robot.
Je faisais à l'époque mes études de doctorat,
Je travaillais en équipe sur le robot humain ;
des équipes humaines et robots travaillant ensemble.
J'étudiais l'ingénierie,
la psychologie et la philosophie du travail d'équipe.
Et en même temps, je me suis retrouvé
dans une situation similaire de travail d'équipe
avec un bon ami à moi qui est présent dans la salle.
Et dans cette situation, nous pourrions facilement imaginer des robots
dans un avenir très proche être là avec nous.
C'était après Pâques.
Nous étions en train de ranger des chaises pliantes,
et j'ai été étonné avec quelle rapidité nous avions trouvé notre propre rythme.
Tout le monde savait ce qu'il avait à faire
Nous n'avons pas eu à diviser nos tâches.
Nous n'avions pas à communiquer verbalement dessus
C'est arrivé naturellement.
Et j'ai pensé :
humains et robots ne ressemblent pas du tout à cela.
Lorsque robots et humains interagissent,
cela ressemble plus à un jeu d'échecs.
L'humain fait quelque chose
le robot analyse ce que l'humain a fait
puis le robot décide quoi faire ensuite,
il le planifie et le fait.
Ensuite l'humain attend, jusqu'à ce que ce soit son tour à nouveau.
Cela ressemble plus à un jeu d'échecs
et c'est logique parce que le jeu d'échecs est idéal
pour les mathématiciens et informaticiens.
Il s'agit avant tout d'analyse de l'information,
de prise de décision et de planification.
Mais je ne voulais pas que mon robot soit un joueur d'échecs,
mais plus l'équivalent d'un homme d'action
ayant la capacité de comprendre et travailler intuitivement en groupe.
J'ai donc fait mon deuxième choix de carrière horrible :
j'ai décidé de prendre des cours d'acteur pendant un semestre.
Je finis mon doctorat et je prends des cours d'acteur.
J'ai même participé à une pièce de théâtre,
J'espère qu'il n'en reste aucune trace filmée…
Et j'ai acheté des tonnes de livres sur le sujet
dont un datant du XIXe siècle
que j'avais récupéré d'une bibliothèque.
Et j'ai été vraiment surpris parce que mon nom était le deuxième sur la liste --
le nom précédent datait de 1889. (Rires)
C'est comme si ce livre avait dû attendre 100 ans
avant d'être redécouvert pour la robotique.
Et ce livre montre aux acteurs
comment associer chacun des muscles de leur corps
pour correspondre à tous les types d'émotion qu'ils veulent exprimer.
Mais la véritable révélation a été
quand j'ai découvert la « méthode Stanislavski »
qui est devenue très populaire au XXe siècle.
Elle expliquait que vous n'avez pas à planifier chaque mouvement de votre corps.
Au lieu de cela, utilisez plutôt votre corps pour trouver le bon mouvement.
Vous devez utiliser votre sens de la mémoire
pour reconstruire les émotions et
penser avec votre corps pour trouver l'expression la plus juste.
Improviser, se servir de son partenaire de scène.
Et cela est arrivé en même temps que je lisais sur la tendance
en psychologie cognitive, appelé « cognition incarnée »,
qui parle aussi des mêmes idées --
nous utilisons tout notre corps pour penser,
et pas uniquement notre cerveau.
Nos corps remontent également les informations à notre cerveau
pour créer la façon dont nous nous comportons.
Ça a été comme un éclair.
Je suis retourné à mon bureau.
J'ai écrit cet article -- que je n'ai jamais vraiment publié
appelé « cours de théâtre pour l'Intelligence artificielle. »
Et j'ai même pris un autre mois
pour faire ce qui était alors la première pièce de théâtre
entre un humain et un robot interagissant ensemble.
C'est ce que vous avez vu précédemment avec les acteurs.
Et j'ai pensé :
comment faire un modèle d'intelligence artificielle--
ordinateur, modèle de calcul --
permettant de modéliser certains concepts empruntés à l'improvisation,
tels que la prise de risque, l'audace et
la capacité à faire des erreurs,
les transformant peut-être en meilleurs coéquipiers robotiques ?
Donc j'ai travaillé pendant un temps assez long sur ces modèles
et je les ai appliqués sur un certain nombre de robots.
Ici vous pouvez voir un exemple très primaire
de robots essayant d'utiliser cette intelligence artificielle,
pour tenter d'imiter mes mouvements aussi fidèlement que possible,
un peu comme un jeu.
Regardons un peu.
Vous pouvez le voir : quand j'en fais trop, il se fait avoir.
Et c'est un peu comme ce que les acteurs font
quand ils essaient de s'imiter
pour trouver le bonne synergie entre eux.
Ensuite, j'ai fait une autre expérience,
j'ai pris des personnes dans la rue pour qu’elles se servent
de la lampe de bureau robot
pour essayer cette idée d'intelligence artificielle incarnée.
Alors, j'ai utilisé deux types de cerveaux pour le même robot.
Le robot est la même lampe que vous avez vue,
et j'ai mis dedans deux cerveaux.
Pour la première moitié du groupe,
j'ai mis un cerveau de robot classique,
un cerveau robotique analytique.
Il attend son tour, il analyse tout, il prévoit.
Appelons-le le cerveau calculateur.
L'autre groupe a eu le cerveau acteur de théâtre, preneur de risque.
Appelons-le cerveau aventurier.
Il agit parfois sans avoir toute l’information nécessaire.
Parfois, il commet des erreurs et les corrige.
Je leur ai attribué une tâche fastidieuse
qui a pris près de 20 minutes
et ils ont dû travailler ensemble.
Une sorte de simulation de travail d'usine
à caractère répétitif.
Et j'ai trouvé que les gens aimaient beaucoup
le robot aventurier.
Ils pensaient qu'il était plus intelligent,
plus engagé, un meilleur membre de l'équipe
ayant davantage contribué au succès du groupe.
Ils l'appelaient même « il » et « elle »,
alors que le groupe avec le cerveau calculateur l'appelait « ça »,
jamais « il » ou « elle ».
Quand ils ont parlé de leur expérience
avec le cerveau aventurier
ils ont dit, « à la fin, nous étions devenus bons amis
et nous nous faisions même des tope-là mentaux. »
Pas évident à faire du tout.
(Rires) Ça a l'air douloureux.
Tandis que les groupes ayant le cerveau calculateur
disaient que c'était comme travailler avec un apprenti paresseux
faisant seulement ce qu'il était censé faire et rien de plus.
Ce qui correspond presque aux attentes qu’ont les gens des robots.
J'ai été surpris de voir que la population générale
attendait plus de la part des robots
que la communauté des concepteurs de robots elle-même.
Et en quelque sorte, j'ai pensé qu'il était peut-être temps--
tout comme la « méthode Stanislavski » a changé la façon dont
les gens imaginaient ce qu'était être acteur au XIXe siècle
passer d’une manière très calculée
et planifiée de jouer et de se comporter,
à une manière plus intuitive et risquée.
Il est peut-être temps pour les robots
d'avoir le même genre de révolution.
Quelques années plus tard,
j'étais à mon travail de recherche suivant à Georgia Tech, Atlanta,
et je travaillais dans un groupe
travaillant avec des musiciens robots.
Et j'ai pensé que la musique, était l'endroit idéal
pour se pencher sur le travail d'équipe, la coordination,
le timing, l'improvisation --
et nous venions de recevoir ce robot jouant le marimba.
Marimba, pour tous ceux comme moi,
c'était ce xylophone en bois, énorme.
Et, quand je regardais cela,
j'ai regardé d'autres travaux d'improvisation homme-robot
-- eh oui, il existe bien d'autres travaux d'improvisation homme-robot --
et ils étaient également un peu comme un jeu d'échecs.
L'homme jouait,
le robot analysait ce qui était joué,
et improvisait alors sa propre partie.
Donc, voilà ce que les musiciens nomment
un appel et une interaction en réponse
et cela convient également très bien aux robots
ainsi qu'à l'intelligence artificielle
Mais j'ai pensé que, si j'utilise les mêmes idées que celles
pour la pièce de théâtre et mes études sur l'esprit d'équipe,
peut-être que je pourrais faire improviser les robots
comme dans un groupe.
Chacun se nourrit de la performance de l'autre, personne ne s'arrête un instant.
J'ai donc essayé de faire les mêmes choses, cette fois-ci avec de la musique,
où le robot ne sait pas vraiment
ce qu'il est sur le point de jouer.
Il bouge juste son corps
et utilise les opportunités qu'il a de jouer,
et fait ce que m'a enseigné mon professeur de jazz quand j'avais 17 ans.
Elle disait : « Quand vous improvisez,
parfois vous ne savez pas ce que vous faites
cependant vous continuez à le faire. »
Et donc j'ai essayé de faire un robot qui ne sait pas réellement
ce qu'il fait, mais le fait quand même.
Regardons quelques instants ce morceau
où le robot écoute le musicien humain
et improvise.
Et puis, regardez comment le musicien humain
répond également à ce que fait le robot et s'inspire
de son comportement.
Et à un moment donné peut même être surpris
par ce que le robot est parvenu à créer.
(Musique)
(Applaudissements)
Être un musicien n'est pas simplement jouer des notes,
sinon personne n'irait voir de spectacle live.
Les musiciens communiquent également avec leurs corps,
avec les autres membres du groupe, avec le public,
ils utilisent leur corps pour exprimer la musique.
Et j'ai pensé, nous avons déjà un musicien robot sur scène,
pourquoi ne pas en faire un musicien à part entière ?
Et j'ai commencé à concevoir une tête socialement expressive
pour le robot.
La tête ne touche pas réellement le marimba,
elle exprime juste ce à quoi correspond la musique.
Voici quelques croquis sur des serviettes de table d'un bar à Atlanta,
qui était dangereusement situé à mi-chemin
entre mon laboratoire et ma maison. (Rires)
Donc j'ai passé, je dirais en moyenne,
trois à quatre heures par jour là-bas.
Je pense… (Rires)
Et je suis retourné à mes outils d'animation en essayant de comprendre
non seulement ce à quoi un robot musicien devait ressembler,
mais surtout comment il devait bouger.
Comment montrer qu'il n'aime pas ce que l'autre personne joue--
et peut-être montrer quel type de rythme il « ressent » à
un moment donné.
Nous avons fini par réunir les fonds pour construire ce robot,
ce qui était plutôt sympa.
Je vais vous montrer maintenant le même genre de performance,
cette fois-ci avec une tête expressive socialement.
Et remarquez la chose suivante --
comment le robot est vraiment en train de nous montrer
le rythme qu'il « ressent » de l'humain.
Nous donnons également à l'homme le sentiment que le robot sait ce qu'il fait.
Et aussi comment le robot modifie son mouvement
dès qu'il commence son propre solo.
(Musique)
Maintenant, il cherche à s'assurer que je suis à l'écoute.
Et maintenant, regardez l'accord final du morceau,
et cette fois-ci le robot communique avec son corps
quand il est occupé à faire son propre truc.
Et quand il est prêt
à coordonner l'accord final avec moi.
(Musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci. J'espère que vous voyez
comment cette partie du corps qui ne touche pas l'instrument
aide réellement le spectacle musical.
Et comme nous sommes à Atlanta, un rappeur
viendra probablement dans notre laboratoire, à un moment donné.
Et nous avons eu ce rappeur qui est arrivé
et a fait une petite session avec le robot.
Et ici vous pouvez voir le robot
réagir au rythme et...
remarquez deux choses. Un, comment c'est irrésistible
d'imiter le robot dans ses mouvements de tête.
Ça vous donne envie de bouger votre propre tête quand il le fait.
Deuxièmement, même quand le rappeur est vraiment concentré sur son iPhone,
dès que le robot se tourne vers lui, il le regarde à son tour.
Même s'il est juste à la périphérie de sa vision --
même du coin de l'œil : ça reste très puissant.
Car nous avons du mal à ignorer
les objets physiques bougeant dans notre environnement.
Nous sommes câblés pour cela.
Donc, si vous avez un problème avec peut-être vos partenaires
qui regardent trop leur iPhone ou smartphone,
peut-être que la présence d'un robot aiderait
à attirer leur attention. (Rires)
(Musique)
(Applaudissements)
Juste pour présenter le dernier robot
sur lequel nous avons travaillé,
quelque chose d'un peu surprenant est apparu :
à un certain moment les gens ne se soucient plus de l'intelligence du robot,
et qu'il puisse improviser et écouter,
faire toutes ces choses de l'intelligence incarnée
que j'ai passé des années à développer.
Ils aimaient vraiment que le robot apprécie la musique. (Rires)
Et ils ne disaient pas que le robot bougeait au rythme de la musique,
mais que le robot appréciait la musique.
Et nous avons pensé, pourquoi ne prenons-nous pas cette idée,
et j'ai conçu un nouveau meuble.
Cette fois ci n'était pas une lampe de bureau mais plutôt une station d'accueil.
C'était une de ces choses sur lesquelles vous branchez votre smartphone.
Et j'ai pensé, que se passerait-il
si votre haut-parleur/station d'accueil ne jouait pas uniquement
de la musique pour vous,
mais était également capable de l'apprécier ? (Rires)
Et encore une fois, voici quelques tests d'animation
à leur stage de développement. (Rires)
Et voici le produit final.
(« Drop It Like It's Hot »)
Donc, beaucoup de hochements de tête.
(Applaudissements)
Beaucoup de hochements de tête dans le public,
donc on peut encore voir comment les robots influencent les gens.
Et ce n'est pas simplement du divertissement.
Je pense que l'une des raisons pour lesquelles j'aime tant
les robots qui utilisent leur corps pour communiquer
et leur corps pour se déplacer --
je vais vous laisser sur un petit secret que nous roboticiens cachons --
c'est que chacun d'entre vous vivra avec un robot
à un certain moment de votre vie.
A un moment donné de votre futur, il va y avoir un robot dans votre vie.
Et si ce n'est pas dans la vôtre, ce sera dans celle de vos enfants.
Et je veux que ces robots soient
plus fluides, plus attrayants et plus gracieux
qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui.
Et pour cela, je pense que peut-être les robots
ont moins besoin d'être comme des joueurs d'échecs
mais plutôt comme des acteurs de scène ou musiciens.
Peut-être qu'ils devraient être en mesure de prendre des risques et d'improviser.
Et peut-être qu'ils devraient être capables d'anticiper
ce que vous allez faire.
Et peut-être qu'ils doivent être en mesure de faire des erreurs
et de les corriger,
parce qu'en fin de compte, nous sommes humains.
Et peut-être en tant qu'êtres humains, des robots
un peu moins que parfaits sont tout simplement parfaits pour nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)